[Music]
you started a kind of a rant about the
expendables movies you sort of went
after
schwartz the cass schwarzenegger
stallone and those guys jean-claude van
damme and you got a ton
of hate tweets i did ton of them let me
just first say i wasn't making fun of
them as much as expressing concern for
their tendons
because although you can get your
muscles that big there's nothing to
really help your tendons stay
so you're slimmer can you remind us what
you were saying you were saying that as
action heroes you don't buy it anymore
you know because they actually can't run
was my point but i don't even want to
rehash that all i wanted to say is i do
want to rehash the point i was making is
that in the movie you'll never see them
chase a bad guy because they can't
i'm just repeating myself but basically
they're like stay here and
fight you run we can't fight because i
can't chase you
that's all
only [ __ ] do more than a walk
so i'm
let's get in the bathtub and fight
[Laughter]
[Applause]
all right so i got all these mad angry
like leave sly alone tweets
and i thought this is where we've come
in this country that i can understand
not making fun of minorities or
homosexuals or some a group that needs
to be protected yes these are
multi-millionaire alpha males ripped to
the gills
superhero men yes the people are
defending yeah it's like if i were
making fun of greek gods and people like
zeus
he's all alone on olympus leave him
alone
leave apollo out of it
i was literally making fun of the
terminator and rambo yes and people felt
the need to protect them from dak
shepard yes
a parenthood the bully yeah the bully
from parenthood
who might be a comedian who even no not
funny enough to be called a comedian no
but what i'm saying is people got very
very angry and did you do you apologize
then or absolutely not yes sir
if we can't make fun of these
alpha males who can we make fun of